[Applaudissements]
mykonos
et elle est
la première la première phase qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est une digue où le
public est d'accord avec moi
mais en fait qu'est ce qui se passait et
a pu des terrains en fait tu t'es tu
t'es tu t'es rasé mais mal
mais tout ce que je fais un verbe n'en
était pas un maire n'était pas du tout
en berne tettey et permet pas je peux
regarder tu peux regarder ses gardes
mais pas toi mais tu as des poils chez
nous savaient pas qu'ils sont comme des
poils de coucou il met sur le
concours m'a dit que j'allais arrêter
d'enlever donc les sahraouis donc tu
attends lever et n'attendez plus et là
j'arrive plus à donc sur la scène voilà
comme vous l'oniam pourra après c'est
bizarre un maire fecteau mois ouais je
pourrais pas ben si tu pourrais tomber
mais alors il a un poil au zizi
il était comme un oeuf je me rappelle
les grandes manoeuvres mais j'ai vu on
se bat là on se douche ensemble à gauche
avec tous les vrais liqueurs à tous les
gens les retouches ensemble et il le
vrai il ya eu à mes joueurs j'ai cru
qu'il avait une vulve
alors plus on l'a tellement circoncis
qu'on a après tiens
me rappelle le jure que c'est vrai ça
doit vous m'avez pas vu plus entendu
tout
et ça c'est nouveau le petit collier de
barbe
de tout faire comme toi nationale à ce
malaise
[Applaudissements]
la qualité de jeu ouais c'est vrai mais
des modernes narnia toujours le trou la
wii toujours toujours et moi bien sûr tu
as si vous savez comment de taux bas là
ça commence à durer ça fait un peu plus
de six mois chez vous ben ouais ces
bovins et vous tout va bien moi ça m'est
égal
[Rires]
de savoir s'il ya bien un moment où faut
pas trop prendre de risques comme ceux
que je viens de faire c'est en fin de
saison pour éviter de se faire virer et
donc du coup j'ai décidé de vous
épargner aujourd'hui c'est ici mais ça
fait plaisir merci non je rigole pas du
tout on sait au contraire concentrer sur
vous cyril puisque vous étiez très
agitée cette semaine j'en ai fait
beaucoup de conneries du coup on a fait
la gazette des off mais spécial barre à
particules
c'est la saison des allergies et à 1 à
dire cyril vous avez l'allergie très
discrète
on continue avec matthieu delormeau qui
visiblement un petit souci avec la
dynastie al oula est la chaussure tour
comment il faut parler de moi toute
façon il me connaît pas trois petits
points forts des familles confrontées ce
qui est du but du cusm
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec celle qui a toujours le
pif toujours et là tu m'en parlera pas
de le penser au fait qu'on fait tes
lèvres
il a fait les lèvres
dr chocraux nimani
la faire un point il a pas un pack c'est
le prêtre michto il a fait les beaux
seins et pommettes
[Applaudissements]
je suis sûr que vous vous posez tous la
question à la maison va-t-il se passer
quelque chose entre mathieu et baba
voici la réponse et si j'avais la
terminale 13 15 jours à vivre non mais
franchement
non mais donc pour te dire que vraiment
sur mer de pie x à ecône en valais pas
bien qu est-ce qui fait mais il écoute
nap's ça lui rappelle un peu sa vie et
ça lui fait du bien
abbas est définitivement l'optique de la
transition
daniel à chaque achat
[Applaudissements]
et au filet avec bavol perturbateurs
mais paris n'en en même temps il ya sept
ans dans l'aventuré pl non pas un truc
qui nous lie à papa perturbateurs
meilleur barman au tessin la seule
personne autour de la table avoir à être
une star du saf et avoir été aussi riche
en millions et j'aime comment tu nous
parles de ta vie de thé déboires des
addictions
[Musique]
moi c'est un jour pour nous il le sait
j'ai pas besoin de lui rappeler
vous décris j'adore
me souviens tu es en fin de
matinée avec de droite
qui les menace mais vous êtes j'adore
vous créez des champions aussi oui la
semaine dernière la france découvrez le
nouveau tube on dirait que tu pue du cul
une célèbre reprise du titre i on dirait
d'avenir avec un mal classé refus de la
manic et l'arbre de voix à couper le
souffle mais sans savoir cyril vous
enchaîner les tubes et cette semaine
vous avez récidivé non vous avez créé un
nouveau titre sur le savoir sauf qu'à
chaque fois vous chanter tout le monde
sur balles et yox
un sofa qui a été élue [ __ ] en chef
cette semaine je regardais le nouveau
titre de série mais regardez qui sent
bien sur ce titre 1
après la chanson de bab al aziza tu pue
du cul que vous avez découvert la
semaine dernière
découvrez son nouveau titre c'est les
anglais
c'est les anglais c'est laissant des
scellés ont
baissé les anglais c'est brian c'est
steven ses ouailles c'est kevin c'est ma
ville c'est pauline c'est les angles
[Applaudissements]
évoquant ces les anglais c'est et dias
c'est 6 watts c'est steven c'est odieux
c'est pourri c'est meilleur ces réseaux
pair
[Applaudissements]
cemex
meilhac
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans
j'adore
[Applaudissements]
chardy la tête c'est bon tu es mort la
jeune et brillant là pour un quart
d'heure
je veux voir de beaux lots
je suis par contre nettement cacahuètes
ça y est tu t'emballes mais non mais
c'est que ça non alors pour ce médecin
on se prend pour un grand bain mathieu
non mais attention
déconnectable revenir vers ses parents
venus encore
je n'ai pas lu la
campagne savamment si vous voulez mettre
monsieur très italien accueille quoi
d'habitude exhorte les motos droite a
tout eu les mots
comme c'est fou ça mathieu c'est le jean
problèmes mais là ça on revient sur un
truc un peu large mais c'est comme ça
mais le tunnel étroit non tout à des tas
d'objets grossistes et pour ceux qui
n'ont pas de voix des gens manche elles
sont très belles ouais et lacs sont pas
mises en valeur par un bon pourquoi en
fait tant pis au sort plus que ta jambe
mais pour toi j'ai pris une chaussure
plus petit d'habitude tu prennes je
prends des skis il est pénible et et
pied sont encore plus grands que tes
jambes
ah bah du coup c'était pas les pieds les
problèmes non mais c'est que j'aime bien
ça fait plaisir c'est rare que vous
validiez majeau bani walid mais c'est
très beau aujourd'hui si nous faisons ça
ne rajoute pas non non c'est vrai non
mais enfin que ça se passe très vite eu
poste ah c'est vrai c'est très gentil de
fin de
mois en mois oui ça mais il ya la queue
pour battre on cherche des saisons donc
autant une petite virée autant que ce
soit pour quelque chose c'est comme la
plus grande foire la saison américaine
star américaine safway alors n'attendez
d'autres pays d'autres je suis un fou
rire aussi l'arrière du plein oui avec
parlant vrai c'est celui qui se détache
et la merguez et sur l'amérique à ce que
vous aviez remis la faute sur quelqu'un
sur qui parce que voir genton sur
guillaume genton bon feeling hier a eu
un nouveau fou rire
avec le fou rire la mallette affichant
diction qu'il a remis la faudrait donc
on voit d'abord l'amérique est ce la
balle au bond
c'est
bien de tuer un chien je parle la chaîne
que je connais acheter malin mois ci où
il vient après aujourd'hui les american
staff en train de les mélanger les uns
avec les autres
c'est facile et il a eu peur il a sauté
j'ai un truc mais tu ne peux pas
derrière la mairie pour le fait que
c'est un chien qui ne risquez rien et
nicolas ça vous fait marrer lakic
identique s ata fema cette femme à rio
donc ça te fait marine
[Applaudissements]
et elle a
du mal à cerner le personnage fait en
deux étapes d'abord le et après il ya
remise de fautes et ben il a fait la
même chose il regarde
ses médiums depuis 35 ans et que j'ai
évolué progressivement sur de la chasse
aux fantômes et sur tout ce qui touche
les phénomènes paranormaux en devenant
experts de cette partie pour moi le
paranormal cdu normal qu'on ne comprend
pas encore aujourd'hui mais qui fait
partie de notre vie de tous les jours
pour travailler dans les habitations et
dans les châteaux mais aujourd'hui il
faut savoir que dans les maisons dans
les hlm il y a aussi des entités il
prend même des questions là à la suite
d'un décès et moi je sortais
effectivement de plusieurs étages et sur
plusieurs maisons
[Musique]
sans lyon je sors tout ça
est alors en fin de compte quand ya
juste une entité qui se trouvent bloqués
dans un endroit elle est dans un endroit
elles ne bougent pas de cet endroit où
faire en période non mais moi je crie ça
c'est bien aux gens tout il est
insupportable oui
tout le monde sait maintenant tu perds
tout le monde s'en va c'est relou je
suis innocent tu as rencontré l'american
staff de
garder aussi
garder les garder oui vous ai préparé du
lourd pour la semaine prochaine fois
sera la dernière chronique de la saison
mais j'ai apporté petit à petit
amuse-gueules site amuse gueules qui dit
fin de saison dit bilan et pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas cyril l'animal faut
savoir que tout ce qui est dit à 19h40
n'est plus valable à 19h40 et 4 secondes
du coup toutes les promesses qu'il a
fait en fin de saison dernière et en
début de saison là c'est bien on l'a
voulu voir si vous les aviez tenu changé
c'est le cimetière de tous
[Rires]
donc je vais vous dire d'ailleurs
l'année prochaine dès 18h45 il y aura
les 15 minutes médias redouane est avec
nous on est bien on va tout de suite
passé au quart d'heure médias 19h52 en
direct vendredi c'est parti le cador
médias car de remédier à la durée de vie
trois émissions secret baba tous les
soirs à 20h10 il aura les fdp
s'appellera les flingueurs du paf on
nous ont rejoints ce sont les flingueurs
du paf qui sont avec nous et elisabeth
lévy et la merci elizabeth
les flingueurs du paf durée de vie
quatre émissions maintenant ils
flinguent chez eux moi je vais te
présenter un nouvel artiste c'est un
artiste s'est beaucoup inspiré de toi
mélanie des bar mitsva ouais il
s'appelle sébastien partouche
et bien et avec nous ce soir
sébastien partouche durée de vie une
émission il anime toujours des bar
mitsva mais chez lui au moment il va
être là tous les jours c'est sa chaise
basse et
le thé mais sacha durée de vie cinq
émissions et c'est déjà trop d'ailleurs
en parlant des autres émissions des
nouvelles séquences ce soir c'est le gps
go si pippo les stars oui on vient de
trouver le titre série à 2h20 c'est
parti les chérit le gps durée de vie six
émissions visiblement il n'a pas trouvé
sa route
[Applaudissements]
april merci d'être avec nous c'est ta
première avec nous visiblement sa
dernière durée de vie une émission
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
annie sa durée de vie deux émissions
depuis elle danse chez m alors c'est la
grande recrue de cette saison ne touche
pas à mon poste c'est sandrine sarroche
mais petit
sandrine sarroche enfin plutôt sandrine
s'arrache durée de vie huit émissions
[Applaudissements]
cueillir leurs émissions pas été une des
révélations l'année dernière on table
une fois que tu as un flash pour toi
comme on dit en italie un flash iman tôt
au lou levy durée de vie deux émissions
depuis il fait des quatre zones à 26
minutes
tous ces gens ont énormément de talent
malheureusement la table n'est pas
d'expressions vie n'aurait vraiment
c'est le problème et reviendront c'est
le prenant vraiment oui j'adore paolo
della d'or a pris le jeu l'adorent
sandrine l'adorent
je
la donne voilà non mais franchement
voilà je suis j'adore ces gens
malheureusement la table n'est pas
extensible faut que je vire des gens
pour faire rentrer
on avance nicolas pernikoff la dernière
nicolas
[Applaudissements]